[Music]
in neil gaiman's
run of the sandman the character death
famously says when the first living
thing existed
i was there waiting
when the last living thing dies my job
will be finished i'll put the chairs on
the tables
turn off the lights and lock the
universe behind me
and when that happens the last creature
death we'll see through the door will
likely be
as the first one was a microbe
their large numbers certainly stack the
odds in their favor but it doesn't hurt
that many microbes
have their own ways of evading what we
have deemed the inevitable
defying death is not as clear cut
as it might initially seem what we
define as
immortality depends a bit on what you
think it means
to die whether it's the loss of your own
individual self or the loss of something
that
has come to exceed you
it also depends on what you think it
means to survive
immortality is not a guarantee of the
microcosmos
there are predators to contend with and
many
simple forces of nature
the tardigrade is famously resilient to
these forces
able to withstand extremes of
temperature radiation
and pressure they can survive these
conditions by
entering cryptobiosis desiccating their
bodies and slowing down their metabolic
rate
as they become a dried-out ball called
a ton the ton state protects the
tardigrade and lets them
wait out the worst for long periods of
time
and that's part of the legend of the
invincible
tardigrade driving our speculation that
they will outlive
us through any apocalypse researchers
have even predicted that tardigrades
could survive
astronomical catastrophes like an
asteroid crashing into our planet
but invincibility is not the same as
immortality
tons have been revived after 30 years of
cryptobiosis but if we exclude the time
spent in cryptobiosis the lifespan of
most
tardigrade species ranges from a few
months
to a few years when these tardigrades
are in their tongue
they're not just protected from the
elements they're also
protected from senescence the thing that
we
call aging senescence is a combination
of many deteriorations both within
cells and across them cells
acquire damage and with time that damage
accumulates and accumulates our bodies
experience that
in the decline of different
physiological functions
and it connects to an increased
mortality as we age
when not in a ton even the mighty
tardigrade experiences senescence
but we know of at least one organism
that does not
scientists studying hydra over several
years
found that the mortality rates over
those years were quite
low but even more striking the hydras
showed
no evidence of aging you might even say
that the hydra remained
forever young
[Music]
they do this by replacing their cells
every 20 days
relying on three core populations of
stem cells
that are themselves continuously and
indefinitely
self-renewing these stem cells
allow the hydra to reproduce asexually
by budding off
and they're also behind the hydra's
legendary powers of regeneration
and these stem cells make the hydra
biologically immortal because its cells
are always being replaced the hydra is
able to
avoid the accumulation of damage that
other multicellular organisms experience
the hydra doesn't age
and so until another force or predator
intervenes
it doesn't die so we have one definition
of immortality that depends on
aging and multicellular organisms but
how does that apply to single-celled
creatures
that reproduce asexually what does
death mean to a single cell that divides
and divides and divides creating a
legacy that is recursively
itself is it enough to just be one of
thousands or tens of thousands of clones
to ensure that even if you die you still
in essence
live in the case of the paramecium
no as each paramecium divides
it ages and it will continue to do so
with each division
with damage accumulating in its dna the
paramecium
will start to divide more slowly and
eventually
the clonal daughter cells will die off
however they can avoid this fate
through conjugation the protist
equivalent of sex
this act is its own sort of rejuvenation
rewinding
the clock for the paramecium scientists
have argued that senescence
originated with protists like the
paramecium but there are signs
that some bacteria experience aging too
they just forestall the effects of an
aging population
by dividing asymmetrically with each
split
one daughter cell will acquire more
damage
than the other and so with each division
one cell will rejuvenate while the other
will age the longevity of the group
is thus built on creating differences
between the seemingly
identical individuals how does this fit
in with
our vision of immortality
it's hard to know at this point the
question of whether we should consider a
flask of bacteria immortal
starts to feel like a matter of
semantics it's informed as much by
personal and philosophical ideas as it
is by
biological ones but of course
some of the most interesting questions
of science and philosophy
boil down to issues of semantics these
aren't just
questions of how the world exists but
also
of how we see the world how we describe
it to each other
how we imagine it for millennia
we've been constructing immortals as
part of our religions
and myths to understand the world around
us
and the stories we tell these immortals
dictate our lives in invisible ways
and they defy the thing we do not want
to face but microbes don't have the same
grandiosity as the mythical figures we
create
they don't need to the hydra may be
biologically immortal but at the end of
the day it's a tube with
arms and the lack of senescence aside
if a predator is able to make the hydra
its prey
the hydra is still quite capable
of dying thank you for coming on this
journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us
and thank you especially to all of these
people our patrons on patreon
who make it possible for us to make this
show
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out
jam and germs on instagram and if you
want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby